some shrimp are unusually scrappy
fighters pistol shrimp and a few dozen
others can snap their claws shut at
ultra-fast speeds the claws closed so
fast that have oils the water around
them creating tiny air bubbles the force
of the water pressure crushing the
bubbles generates a shock wave that
stuns the shrimp's prey how claws that
evolved for simple pinching aimed the
ability to close so quickly was a
mystery to biologists a team of
researchers looked closely at the claw
anatomies of a hundred and fourteen
shrimp species they found two types of
claw joints that no one had noticed
before the first was a basic slip joint
like you'd find in a Swiss Army knife
a tiny ridge creates pressure as the
claw closes allowing it to snap shut a
little more quickly that basic slip
joint set the evolutionary stage for a
further modification the cocking slip
joint with this joint the ridge [ __ ]
the cloth fully opened building of
tremendous muscle tension before the
shrimp releases it the scientists 3d
printed models of the various joints and
found that a claw with a cocking slip
joint can snap closed with enough force
to generate shock waves so maybe now
you'll think twice the next time you go
toe-to-toe or clawed a claw with a
pint-sized pistol shrimp
[Music]
[Music]